[Música]
porque nosotros en nuestros territorios
tendríamos mejores condiciones de vida
mi hijo no tendría una necesidad de
migrar o no tendría necesidad de ser
jornalero si tuviera las condiciones
para poder trabajar la apicultura para
poder sembrar la milpa
en general es indígena sin territorio no
existe vida la vida de las selvas donde
a todos nuestros familiares para común a
las marcas que pasó por muchos un gas
soy una mujer que trae muchas marcas que
pasa por muchos lugares que tienen
muchas realidades que dormía en la calle
que se prostituía que conocía la
realidad del abandono familiar del
rechazo pero nada de eso fue motivo para
que me debilitará toda esa lucha me
alimento todos mis dolores me ayudaron a
entender qué es la violencia estructural
y a transformar mis dolores en una
fuerza para luchar no sólo para mí para
todos nosotros y para lo está no fue por
mí
[Música]
simplemente diré que alemania es un país
fuerte y nuestro motivo con el que
debemos abordar esto tiene que ser
logramos mucho podemos hacer esto
podemos conseguirlo y donde hay
obstáculos hay que superarlos
-usted muchas ideas
[Música]
y seremos una institución que se
despierta cada mañana pensando en ti y
tus trabajos sus sueldos tus luchas sus
esperanzas tu dignidad y tu potencial
ilimitado
washington
entre nosotras socialmente
ya lo hablamos entre muchas mujeres
jóvenes y no jóvenes para hablamos yo
puedo hablar de esto con mi mamá o
hablar de esto con mi abuela
y este y ahí me enteré que a ellas
también han abortado
pensamos que a partir de ahí posee
seguir caminando con esas
y alianzas con esas luchas y respetando
sus trabajos de cada quien pero
caminando hacia
de esta defensa del territorio como
decimos
es una nueva página para el golf
femenino estoy muy feliz y orgullosa de
ser parte de eso ya sabes como dijiste
la única jugadora árabe de la historia
es realmente algo de lo que estoy
orgullosa por tener la posibilidad de
representar al mundo a la vez mi región
no es que uno sea combativo luchadora
porque amaneció hoy día yo creo que es
una capacidad mínima de de sensibilidad
con lo que pasa con el mundo y para el
mundo se está en un momento muy álgido
de violencia en el mundo y ahí va
creciendo como ha ido creciendo el
capitalismo también o sea es cosa de ver
también el tema el autoritarismo en el
mundo
[Música]
y estoy feliz de recibir el reinado por
historia de un hijo y también estoy
feliz de pensar que los libreros ahora
que finalmente han podido reabrir sus
puertas podrán continuar apoyando mis
libros como lo han hecho durante 20 años
así que es un gozo un gozo compartido
[Música]